these social media platforms are
designed over all else to maximize
engagement when you open up your
instagram or your twitter and you think
you're seeing your community you think
you're seeing your friends your family
or you think you're seeing the voices
you follow the people you want to hear
from and when you interact with them the
feedback that you get in terms of what
travels what gets likes what doesn't get
likes you think that that is feedback
from real people but
these are overwhelmingly the choices of
these automated systems that are
deciding
what's going to get attention what's not
going to get attention because the
amount of content that's on social media
is huge and the amount of content you
can see is tiny so we can tell
almost any story at once
by what it pulls out and what presents
to you and how it presents it to you and
it smuggles its choices through your
community in a way that
feels neutral but is not and
in a way that has much more power to
affect how you think and how you feel
then you might believe